charles is in toledo hey charles how are
you
i am great uh glad that i found you
on the radio sorry on on my heart
actually
a friend of mine years ago introduced me
to
some of your methods not to you so
that kind of slowed my progress down a
lot i could have been doing a lot more
sooner but
i am uh 50 um pretty much debt free
except for
mortgage and when i start
putting in it's a zero percent mortgage
so it kind of doesn't make sense to
really save a lot of money to skip the
401k to pay that off
um but i can do that but so
the point is um
does the financial peace university
or the dan ramsey plus
teach me how much of my money
i can spend where for example
i like to take my wife and kids out to
dinner
but i don't know i can't find online how
much am i allowed to allocate towards
that per
month i'm a late saver uh just you know
i only have about 20
000 in my roth ira at the moment
so i do want to put in as much as i can
in july i'm eligible for a rough
401k but they will match seven percent
so i want to
do that that's great well budget
percentages would change
depending on your situation if you're in
what we call baby step two
meaning you're clearing off all your
debts except your home and i think
that's where you said you are
you know if you're already past baby
step two then
uh you know yes you can allocate some
you can lighten up your percentages and
allocate some for fun
some for restaurants and vacations and
those kinds of things
if you are in the get out of debt mode
gazelle intensity and baby step two
the the allocated percentage for
restaurants is zero
the allocated percentage for vacation is
zero
while you work your way out of debt and
it's not like dave ramsey's punishing
somebody like some of these idiots say
on social media
but it's more like uh this is how you
win right
you have to pay a price to get out of
debt it's how i won you have to pay a
price to get out of debt it's not easy
it's hard
now but but as you go along yes there
are some
uh guidelines we've got some percentages
some of them are in the back of the
different books
in uh for instance total money makeover
i think there's a percentage guidelines
on the in the forms
section in the back of the book they'll
analog forms i don't think there are
percentages
in every dollar if i remember in the
budgeting
app which is really what i recommend you
use but if you're just looking for some
guidelines
there's that now one that is well known
is we tell folks not to have more than
25 percent of your income take-home pay
going out in housing
your house payment and so there you are
uh but you know what what ends up
happening is this it the percentages
don't matter as much as
every dollar that goes to one thing
can't go to another
and once you start doing that with your
spouse then you say
then you come to an agreed amount for
restaurants right
and it's you know and so if you make 70
000
a year the agreed amount for restaurants
is not 700 a month
right because you can't hit your other
goals and you're going to make those
decisions automatically
when you're looking at it but there's
not a magic formula that says you know
if you just limit your restaurants to
this
but but instead you start making wise
decisions that everything
every budget category is a trade-off
putting money in one
by definition means there's no money for
the other one
and i like what rachel talks about is
asking yourself that next layer which is
why are you buying that are you buying
another shirt
you have money in your clothing budget
because you actually need new clothes
great
are you buying stuff new clothes because
you're
that's that's your addiction right yeah
that is a way you're wallpapering over
some some other stuff you need to be
dealing with
so i like to ask myself and the eating
out thing is that that's right it's not
for showing off for other people but
you know why are we eating out so much
right is it because we don't like
spending time at home
is it because one of us doesn't want to
cook or doesn't like to cook or we can't
get to the store or is it just because
at the end of the day we just it's a
form of entertainment that's right
you know and so are we you know what's
going on with that why is it why are we
doing that